zach is on the line in Morgantown West
Virginia hey Zack welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey Dave how are you done
better than I deserve what's up hey um
so I have been working your plan with my
fiance for a little over a year now
we've made quite a lot of progress
towards our outrageous outstanding that
we have about a quarter million dollars
between the both of us most of which is
student loans the vast majority of it so
how much we paid on we've actually in
the last about 13 months and we've paid
off close to $30,000 very good and so
who's the doctor or the lawyer she is
the physician's assistant okay oh and I
am I'm in retail so am i my student loan
that's from two years of college we're
very minimal and they have been cents
paid off but her PA her PA bills still
laying there yeah okay oh yeah but
what's your household want me going to
be we we currently make about 180 don't
come so our shovel is a pretty decent
size so I'm thankful for that are you
are you working on this together in some
way or just walking beside each other
while you're engaged or because if if a
couple were married in making 180 and
the only paid off 30 in 13 months I
wouldn't call that good well yeah I
agree with you it is it is a far cry
from where we need to be and we are
especially more in the last few months
we are 100% on board together okay so
our we share a bank account now and all
of our money is budgeted out written out
on paper now so you know $30,000 a lot
of that was making minimum payments yeah
so we have we have kicked it into high
gear so to speak do you want to get
married we've been engaged for two years
yeah I wasn't married so yeah
wondering what you would recommend doing
as far as the debt snowball goes we have
such a lot of ground to cover yet it was
okay to put something like that on hold
so what would you spend on a wedding we
went over at all and we want to spend
about 15,000 okay that's like one
month's income counting taxes you make
180 a year that's 15,000 a month yep
yeah we see after taxes and we do feel a
little bit less than that obviously yeah
but I guess my point is I yeah
two months save everything you stopped
for two months and save everything you
can and get married on whatever that is
but that oughta be able to get close to
15 on that and then then let's roll up
our sleeves and stay on that kind of a
course because you know out of a hundred
and eighty if you can't put a hundred
towards your dad I mean you gotta let us
something yeah and I mean a lot of our
month-to-month expenses is paying on
these loans and where we live and
believe it or not in West Virginia is
quite expensive to live you make a
hundred an eighty you live in Morgantown
pay a hundred a year off and be
debt-free in two and a half years and
yes I set up your debt snowball
temporarily for a little bit and and
knock the wedding out that's what I
would do yeah but look there really you
make there's no excuses allowed here you
cannot spend money like you make it you
know you've got a disaster on your hands
here so you guys got to act like the
building's burning down but yeah just
for real quick just tap the brakes save
up the money get married get married
then let's then let's tear into this
whole hog but you don't need to be
buying anything or traveling or going
out to eat or buy anything you have a
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
mess to clean up so you really got to
focus on that no excuses